This is no ordinary rocket engine.
Limited by the technology of their times engineers
and physicists have theorized this propulsion
method for centuries, but the constraints
of time may have just lifted with NASA’s
revolutionary test of this rotating detonation
engine in January 2023.
With the very latest advances in material
science and computational fluid dynamics,
NASA has managed to break through to test
a 3D printed rocket engine that could improve
fuel efficiencies of rockets by up to 5%.
[1]
A 5% improvement in fuel efficiency for a
rocket engine is not a marginal gain.
Rocket weights are dominated by fuel.
The 1st stage Saturn V had a dry mass of 137,000
kilograms, when fully loaded with propellant
its weight was 2.2 million kilograms.
The first stage was 94% fuel.
A 5% increase in fuel efficiency represents
a 103 tonne decrease in fuel.
That’s not far off the total dry weight
of the Falcon 9 rocket.
[2]
This does not just provide cost savings.
It represents a drastic change in capabilities
of rockets.
Allowing humans to launch larger payloads
further into the solar system.
This latest test of the technology saw the
engine run 18 times, with a maximum firing
duration of 113s seconds per run.
[3]
This was a test, and the engine is not ready
to use, but this test represents the culmination
of decades of research, enabled by newly developed
metals and manufacturing techniques and the
very latest advances in computational fluid
dynamic modeling.
Let's delve into the science and engineering
behind Rotating detonation engines to see
how they work.
Engines powered by detonations are not a new
concept.
The Air Force Research Laboratory developed
this heavily modified Rutan Long EZ.
Powered by 4 tubes in which the detonations
occurred.
Traditional rocket engines work by mixing
fuel and an oxidizer, using a continuous igniter.
With the ignitor typically located at the
top of the combustion chamber, a flame front
needs to travel through the fuel mixture to
complete combustion.
If the speed of this flame front is below
supersonic speed, the combustion is called
deflagration.
If the “flame front” travels through the
mixture at over Mach 1, then the process is
called detonation.
Almost all combustion engines work with deflagrations,
but as their name implies Rotating detonation
engines use a supersonic flame front to produce
thrust, and as a result can produce more thrust
for the same volume of fuel.
However, this is easier said than done.
The energy needed to initiate a detonation
is very large, and for these pulsed detonation
engines used on the Air Forces test vehicle,
the detonations needed to happen hundreds
of times a second.
We can initiate a normal deflagration combustion
flame front, which travels along the tube
and with some encouragement will transition
to a detonation, but the causes of this aren’t
totally understood and are not always reliably
repeatable.
We know that detonations happen more often
when the fuel is turbulent so to create these
conditions, pulsed detonation engines often
include physical barriers.
One method to achieve this is by placing a
spiral inside the tube.
[4]
Pulsed detonation has a more obvious problem.
They don’t provide constant thrust.
They pulse.
Rotating detonation engines are the solution
to both of these problems.
They consist of a ring shaped combustion chamber.
The process starts by opening a valve at one
end of a tube and letting a fuel mixture fill
the tube.
The valve closes and an ignition source at
the closed section goes off and the detonation
begins.
A shockwave begins to travel around the circumference
of the ring that increases the pressure and
temperature of the gas behind it almost instantaneously.
This gas then expands and leaves the tube
at extremely high velocity, creating thrust.
This cycle then repeats with the shockwave
traveling in a never ending circle.
This clever arrangement solves the major problems
with pulsed detonation engines by having to
only set off the detonation once, it eliminates
the unreliability of setting off thousands
of detonations a second and its continual
spiral around the combustion chamber results
in consistent thrust.
Keep in mind these detonation fronts are going
FAST, operating at Mach 3-6 depending on the
fuel mixture.
This means that the waves complete a full
circle in a thousandth of a second, with operating
ranges between 1 to 10 kHz [5].
This is an incredibly difficult phenomenon
to harness.
Detonations release energy very quickly, are
hard to control, and are unstable by nature.
In fact, for the last century of aerospace
advancement, engineers have been working very
hard to prevent detonations in their rocket
nozzles.
During the development of the F1 engine in
the Apollo program, the engineers struggled
to control what they called “thermodynamic
instabilities”.
These were in fact detonations that were destroying
the engine.[6]
On June 28th 1962 these combustion instabilities
caused an engine to be completely destroyed
during testing.
This problem was plaguing the engineers of
the Saturn V and is arguably the greatest
challenge they faced in scaling this monstrous
rocket to reach the moon.
A list of 18 potential sources of the instability
were made.
This was an incredibly complex and dynamic
problem.
One method to reduce instabilities and to
prevent pressure waves from amplifying off
the side walls, like a sound wave, was to
install baffles that separated the combustion
chamber radially.
Several iterations of baffles were designed,
but with no computational method available
the engineers of the F1 engine turned to the
next best practical method.
They set off tiny bombs inside the combustion
chamber during operation to quickly induce
small combustion instabilities.
The combustion chamber bomb was attached to
the injector plate with the detonator inside
the combustion zone.
The detonator was encased in nylon that would
ablate away in the heat of combustion over
time, allowing the engine to reach full operation
before detonating.
Resulting in a pressure wave that traveled
through the engine just as a combustion instability
would.
The engineers could test the effectiveness
of new baffle designs by timing how long it
took for normal operation to resume after
the detonation.
These baffles effectively acted as acoustic
dampeners, like the foam wedges we place in
sound treated rooms.
For decades engineers have been working to
prevent these uncontrollable dynamic detonations.
But engineers and scientists are stubborn
kinds of people.
When they hear “uncontrollable” all they
hear is “not yet controlled”.
And rotating detonation engines effectively
use the exact phenomenon that these baffles
were trying to prevent, allowing a traveling
shockwave to travel tangentially around a
ring shaped combustion chamber.
The appeal of using detonations as a combustion
and propulsion mechanism is precisely what
makes them dangerous, their quick release
of energy.
We can visualize the amount of energy we can
extract by comparing the combustion cycle
of a hypothetical detonation engine and a
normal gas turbine engine on a pressure-volume
chart.
This chart simply plots the pressure and volume
of air as it travels through an engine.
In a gas turbine, the air enters the engine
at this pressure and volume.
A compressor decreases its volume at a constant
pressure.
It then moves to the combustor where heat
is added in at a constant pressure.
Then the gas passes through a turbine as it
expands until it reaches its initial condition.
The energy we extracted can be found by finding
the area enclosed by these curves.
In a detonation cycle we skip the combustor
stage completely, and instead the detonation
wave increases the pressure of the gas almost
instantaneously.
Spiking it much higher.
This creates a much larger area inside the
curves.
The theoretical differences in thermodynamic
efficiencies using this analysis method are
immense.
Using hydrogen as our gas, a gas turbine engine
has a thermodynamic efficiency of 36.9% while
a detonation engine has a thermodynamic efficiency
of 59.3%.[5].
Simply, this means that more energy is extracted
from the same amount of fuel.
However, an increase in energy yield is of
no use to us if we can’t control it, or
it simply destroys our engine.
To harness his energy we needed to develop
new materials and manufacturing techniques.
This is where a new material, specially developed
for metallic 3D printing comes into play.
Data sheet on table GRCOP-42.
A nasa developed alloy made up of niobium,
chromium and copper.
A high strength metal alloy specially formulated
to not only have a very high melting point,
but a high thermal conductivity.
Meaning it takes more energy to melt it and
it conducts the energy away more efficiently
to prevent itself from melting, and critically,
NASA has more recently developed a method
of using it metallic 3D printing, meaning
we can create incredibly complex geometries
with this new age material.
Maintaining this reaction is incredibly difficult.
The shockwave, by nature, is traveling incredibly
fast, and causes rapid changes of temperature
and pressure.
Take the injectors.
They have to be designed to handle not only
high flow rates but also drastic changes in
pressure and temperature.
As the shockwave travels by condition change
from 0.01 Megapascals of pressure at 300 kelvin,
to 2 megapascals of pressure and 3000 kelvin.
That cycle happens one thousand times per
second.[7]
Our copper based alloy can help us dissipate
that energy, but these inlets need to switch
from injecting gas to resisting the pressure
of the shockwave in milliseconds.
To manufacture an inlet capable of handling
these conditions the engineers needed 3D printing.
A typically machined injector may look something
like this, but the designers of the rotating
detonation engine need to handle back flow,
and for this they can turn to fluid diodes,
which would be impossible to manufacture with
traditional cutting tools.
The shape of this passage allows fuel to flow
easily in one direction, but when flow attempts
to travel in the opposite direction it impinges
itself, resisting flow.
Effectively it’s a valve with no moving
parts.
A perfect solution for this application.
[8]
The use of metal 3d printing doesn't stop
at inlet design.
Every part of the rotating detonation engine
requires delicate shaping to harness the power
of detonation.
From the combustion chamber design to ensure
the shockwave remains in rotating to the tiny
cooling channels running through its walls.
The rotating detonation engine that NASA developed
used a 3D-printed thrust chamber that was
actively cooled using Deionized water.[3]
It also features an aerospike nozzle.
Aerospike nozzles are kinda like inside-out
nozzles.
Instead of the traditional bell shaped nozzle,
it features a cone at the center of the exhaust.
Aerospike nozzles allow the rocket to operate
more efficiently at a range of altitudes.
To understand why, we need to cover some basics
of nozzle design.
The bell nozzle operates optimally at a certain
external atmospheric pressure.
To work at its most efficient we want the
exhaust pressure at the nozzle exit to equal
the external atmospheric pressure.
If the external pressure is higher than the
exhaust exit pressure we are operating in
the overexpanded condition.
Flow separation from the nozzle occurs and
energy is lost.
If the external pressure is lower than the
exhaust exit pressure we are operating in
the underexpanded condition, the gas expands
outwards outside of the nozzle and energy
is lost.
However if we match the exit pressure and
atmospheric pressure neither happens and exhaust
velocity is maximized, making our engine more
efficient.
We could fit rockets with variable geometry
nozzles like fighter jets, but this would
add a lot of weight, complexity and cost.
These nozzles are a lot bigger than fighter
jets and until very recently were single use.
[9]
Aerospikes provide a lighter simpler alternative
to variable geometry exhausts.
Here the shape of the exhaust is dictated
by the external atmospheric pressure.
At higher pressures, at lower altitudes, the
exhaust is compressed against the aerospike,
which redirects the exhaust to point straight
down.
No flow separation can occur as the pressure
is pushing it against the aerospike.
As pressure lowers this expansion continues,
and the aerospike automatically compensates
to external pressure changes.
The exact science of these aerospike nozzles
is a lot more complicated than this and deserve
a video entirely dedicated to them alone.
But they are uniquely suited to rotating detonation
engines, as an aerospike engine, with this
cone design, requires a circular combustion
chamber, which the rotating detonation engine
also requires.
However these is a more important reason,
to optimize the design of a bell nozzle we
need a consistent chamber pressure in order
to optimize our expansion ratio, with the
rotating detonation engine the chamber pressure
is constantly changing along the circumference
of the combustion chamber.
The aerospike's ability to adapt to external
atmospheric pressures also helps it adapt
to internal chamber pressure changes.
[10]
There is a lot more to do to make rotating
detonation engines viable.
These prototypes, while promising, struggle
to run for long enough to produce prolonged
thrust.
In 2021, Japan tested a rotating detonation
engine in space, which operated for 6 seconds,
producing 500 Newtons of thrust, and while
this was a proof of concept it’s a long
way from the millions of Newtons traditional
rocket engines can achieve.[11]
The mechanics of detonations are still not
understood fully.
This means that maintaining a stable detonation
front is extremely difficult.
The system is inherently chaotic.
Engineers are fighting against entropy to
control these powerful turbulent flow regimes.
With each revolution of the shockwave more
chaos is introduced to the system.
A single vortex on revolution one can cause
a ripple effect until the rotation becomes
completely unstable by rotation 20.
NASA even stated that their tests sometimes
fluctuate from have 2 to 5 co-rotating detonation
waves in the combustion chamber at once.[12]
This NASA test was a huge milestone for the
technology.
They demonstrated that their copper based
3D printed material could survive for long
enough in this environment with their longest
run lasting nearly 2 minutes, and they managed
to successfully initiate the detonation front
multiple times with 17 restarts over 600 seconds.
The biggest challenge facing engineers of
rotating detonation engines is creating flow
models to predict these instabilities and
developing methods to dampen and control these
combustion instabilities, just as the engineers
of the Apollo program did all the way back
in the 1960s.
The next real engineering video is ready right
now.
It’s about the M1 Abrams.
We detail it’s unique turbine engine, an
engine type typically used in aircraft, but
used in this heavy armored vehicle for 2 special
reasons.
We dig into how the armor of the M1 has evolved
over the past 4 decades and how it works.
It will be available on YouTube in 2 weeks,
but you can watch it now, before anyone else
on Nebula, as a thank you to our show's supporters.
Here’s a rapid fire list of incredible features
you can enjoy for the low cost of just 2 dollars
50 a month.
Ad free videos
Early access before anyone on YouTube
Exclusive behind the scenes of our documentaries,
like these 2 uncut interviews from our Helion
Documentary
Exclusive classes and originals from me and
all your favorite creators.
I know they are your favorite, because it
tells me what channels my viewers watch in
my analytics.
We got Mustard, Wendover Productions, Practical
Engineering, the list goes on.
And here’s the incredible thing , by signing
up with my link you aren’t just supporting
me.
You are supporting educational creators across
the board, because we all own a percentage
of this platform.
We created it to give us creative freedom,
and we have achieved it.
Nebula is the lifeblood of our channel.
As sponsors and ad revenues have dropped off
lately, Nebula is what is ensuring our incredible
team of writers, animators and editors across
Real Engineering and Real Science, including
myself, can feel secure in uncertain financial
times, and that’s thanks to you.
Real Engineering started with just me.
I barely knew how to animate.
I just had a dream of recreating the magic
I felt watching nature documentaries on TV
growing up, but for engineering.
Over the past 6 years I have continually reinvested
revenue to hire the incredible people that
make this channel possible.
Mike, Dylan, Stephanie, Eli, Kirtan, Lorraine,
Josi, Graham.
This channel is not just me.
It’s a group of dedicated people that you,
our viewers, employ.
If you want to see Real Engineering continue
to evolve and increase in production value,
this is how you support that mission.
2 dollars 50 a month for the annual plan,
and you get all that incredible content to
boot.